- I've always been an
admirer of animation.
It's an art form where
literally anything is possible.
(pensive music)
As someone who is on the autism spectrum,
there are certain things
that I struggle with.
I figured that working
in the field that I have
so much love for was nothing
more than like a pipe dream.
To feel like I've been
given this opportunity
to prove myself, it's such
a amazing experience.
My name is David Miles.
I'm a junior VFX artist and animator
here at Exceptional Minds.
- This is gonna be a
great class, you guys.
And look around, these
are gonna be the people
you're gonna work with
for a long time, too.
Exceptional Minds is this amazing school
for young adults on the autism spectrum.
We teach them visual
effects and animation.
Students go through a three-year program
where they learn the basics of animation
and visual effects, and then they learn
compositing and editing, so that they know
how to tell a story.
The vast majority of
people with autism have
extreme trouble finding work.
We're trying to create a place where
people can take advantage
of their talents,
and they can reach great heights.
- This is an animation project I did
in my first year, made entirely in Flash.
I'm gonna be starting an
internship at Cartoon Network,
which I'm incredibly excited about.
Knowing that I can make
a career out of this
is probably one of the biggest reliefs,
one of the best feelings
that I have ever experienced.
One of the things I've discovered
being around other people
who are on the autism
spectrum is that there is such
a great variety of personality,
of creative potential.
I've seen people who can
do absolutely mind-blowing
things with special
effects, with animation.
There is a certain advantage
to being able to think
very differently from the typical person.
(electronic ping)